[Musique]
avec ses yeux indépendants l'un de
l'autre
ses mains aux allures de pinces et sa
langue au point son exceptionnelle
le caméléon est un animal peu ordinaire
or on a percé récemment un ses secrets
les mieux gardés
ces changements de couleurs
spectaculaires
[Musique]
une équipe suisse qui étudie la peau des
reptiles sous toutes ses coutures s'est
intéressé à une espèce qu'on retrouve à
madagascar
le caméléon panthères contrairement à la
croyance populaire ce n'est pas pour se
camoufler qu'il se métamorphose au
naturel le mar les verts ils se font
déjà dans le feuillage et sa tenue reste
identique
ma mission change de décor mais pour
séduire une femelle ou défiait rival le
vert s'efface en une minute
le caméléon panthères affiche fièrement
ses couleurs tape à l'oeil pour changer
de couleur bien des animaux ont recours
à des pigments qui se répandent dans les
cellules de la peau grâce à des canaux
spécialisés
les caméléons ont trouvé mieux
le mâle adulte développe une couche de
peau spécialisé dans les jeux de lumière
sous son épiderme
on retrouve à la fois des cellules
remplies de pigment jaune et d'autre de
petits cristaux de guanyin quand
l'animal est calme ces cristaux
réfléchissent la lumière bleue elle se
combine aux jaunes des pigments pour
donner à la peau sa couleur verte
mais quand le caméléon est excité et
séduit le gonfle à mesure que les
cristaux s'éloignent les uns les autres
ils réfléchissent de nouvelles couleurs
à preuve cette cellule de peau d'abord
rouge devient tour à tour orange et
jaune verte et enfin turquoise
le tout en quelques minutes de tous les
reptiles
le caméléon mal serait le seul à avoir
développé ces couches de peau serti de
cristaux qui font danser la lumière pour
charmer sa belle c'est bien connu rien
de tel que les diamants aussi petit
soit-il
[Musique]